okay
saving checkpoint apparently but maybe
not cuz saves our funky hello everybody
my name is markiplier I had to play
through that hoping section again
because it was kinda [ __ ] then rate
secret you are oh oh you bet but
actually I've already got it where is it
aha here we go
classified files formally request
indefinite leave of absence family
matters great file to patient experience
severe regular incidents of rage
hallucinations associated otherworldly
beings claims one such being is out to
get him Chris dosage of Enzo diazepam
solitary confinement good i feei agree
oh that is different what is that
alright so some kind of symbol I don't
know if that's supposed to be memorized
but I'm not going to Oh symbol torn up
interesting and crumpled symbol on
ground maybe same picture of symbol on
ground but slightly blurry ER to whom it
may concern' an officer below we have
decided that it would be best in your
best interest to place you on temporary
leave for an indeterminate amount of
time we understand that the incident
witnessed on blank was traumatizing for
you and decided to grant your request
for a leave of absence further we have
taken precautions for a temporary
replacement we'd recommend that you
enroll at blank psychiatric facility
yeah that's good yeah that's good
missing person probably the developer of
the game I assume five days ago around
blank if you have any information about
his whereabouts please please please
contact family reward offered a video of
the symbol on the ground
okay that was helpful in June of 1957
multi-billionaire learned of an infamous
name tablet while thousands of years ago
for the context in dark dark places an
artifact said to be a connection to the
disco with the help of his insatiable
lust for the tablet millions of dollars
worth of disposable income and knowledge
of what powered the tablet holds he
tossed a group of ocular gist with
locating the tablet through the method
okay mr. SCP okay sure thing SCP min you
can probably guess what happened next a
mistake perhaps to awaken sleeping and
bring it to this world obviously this is
just the beginning of the hell to come
okay darker blur
it wasn't until January of 1975 almost
20 years of searching they successfully
located the tablet the tablet was
recovered the calls are formed and the
new members were initiated construction
immediately began on the engine to house
a tablet and hidey-hole well testing
begins to take place some kind of SCP
[ __ ] going on here okay all right
umm confidential a boss very
confidential a door a very confidential
ah gate very very confidential war
writing on the walls confidential are
you okey alright cool
I don't know if any of that was
pertaining to what we were going to
having going on here but I know that my
battery is weightless
and everywhere I go uh Melanie a little
bit creepy man get over it some youtube
going on here it's not just about you
that's mostly about you I have no idea
what I need to do now what do I need to
do now
Oh also I learned that you could pick up
rats because I had to play through this
a bunch and you can throw eat that rat
ok so there's got to be something that
open door turned on
what
okay I don't know if this okay it's just
looping do I go here why oh oh oh it's a
puzzle oh yeah okay I see I see yes yes
I see wait do they all need to be open
or closed
what's what's the thing here what's the
story of a dude BAM
ooh hey okay God that running is still
so topsy-turvy
[Music]
stable realms of reality
I've seen reality and in front
all of them are shadeless
there are voices that we don't
understand we'll know the truth of that
just startled me
uh-huh okay well I have this now bow
before my powerful candle my candle of
Michael hi
[Laughter]
okay you study that tablet man of
knowledge I'm sure that it's gonna go
swimmingly for you thunk can I get a
checkpoint or something whoa oh yeah guy
I don't have my flashlight oh I do but I
didn't have it anymore how about this
story this looks important what rid the
key I have go
no no no no you wanna yeah
sometimes if you just hold your breath
oh my that really was that really was
this on fire there was just a blazing
inferno in here okay that makes sense
[Laughter]
I know you were not really taking this
whole thing seriously are you you don't
think your eternal life is worth the
lodge of others
takes to stay this
you don't sound very young so if I could
you be this way forever I would be so
happy
okay all right weird um so there's a
cult and also some science and all of
it's trying to get immortality and it
requires some sacrifices and this fire
is just burning forever that doesn't
make any sense it's also a very loud
fire so fires just glow in the dark hey
that's cool Wow
okay anything in here of use-value sure
wish I could hear stuff over this
goddamn inferno
I've got another key there's another
door down here so I'm assuming that this
is the one that I need yep yeppers
peppers oh I can't move oh hey did I do
it
oh [ __ ] I did it chapter one thank God
there was only one checkpoint in that
whole chapter oh where are we now
oh no not a glimpse of hope it's gonna
be taken away if you say that it's a
glimpse of hope you don't know that it
can't open just won't open right now
okay hi oh boy this place is gonna be
big ain't it oh it's gonna be big what
the hell oh oh hey okay so I think this
is a clock hand
well that was loud
does EIU okey in here yet prisons is me
like ah why would they have light
switches those don't exist okay it
doesn't seem like he's unleashed yet so
I'm assuming that everything is gonna be
hunky-dory
oh no the awards while the presents also
why does it constantly seem like there's
gunk on my face like this light is more
obscuring my vision than actually
illuminating I think you screw you I
can't see I got a shock this rat
[Laughter]
I heard he listened to that one they did
the developer expects not everyone to
get that one frigging repeats over here
rat yeah being careful for nerds I go
boldly wherever I please
rat come here oh don't you run away from
me I'll get you you think you're scared
to the IU okey wait till you get a lot
of me
I checked your friend you know what I do
to you hold on dear we're just a little
bit longer
I need a running start for this one
since cute little movies
the circle starts escaping a small bill
previously informed
the neurosurgeon dr. Grayson our study
to tablet and the protection cervical
should be super plated that sturdy
screen it still American my French was
not as simple as that
banging into the countless sacrifices
that must be made there's something else
if I'm correct one of the inscriptions
on the tablet says that the Delta asks
for a return of eternal youth a young
fresh verse appears so a jar
politics
okay so people are giving children to
the IU oh no to the IU Oh keys so that
they can be granted eternal youth and
how exactly does the IU okie if that is
what they're sacrificing too how does
that give them eternal youth does it
just like shoot ya know you talk now yep
does it just shoot its magic into them
like how does it do it I know this is
very scientific but how exactly can I
have this all right so how do I get this
on you oh okay well that's one if it's a
big hand or the little hand that looks
like the little hand actually so there's
got to be a big hand around here
somewhere oh yeah my oh my oh wow I
cannot see it is too bright and the dirt
on my face making it difficult is there
supposed to be
oh that can't be good
baby's stomach check more rats peas the
god you want fresh young Souls this wait
till I hock a couple rats your way Dan
you're gonna love me I've got myself
around look well why is it I can't see
why is it burning oh are you okay
you need a rat okay well he's definitely
dead not gonna get back up anytime soon
so I'm in the clear
I'm in the good free oh hey yeah oh I
did have the long end this is the short
end okay let's be on my way hey see you
around buddy and you enjoy that retina
all right you get back in there now you
you you you get I can't close this okay
you know baby okay up uppy uppy uppy
uppy okay well that was fun
do you worship me as your God now do I
get eternal youth is this all symbology
for setting setting the clock back on my
youth okay so now what I was kind of
expecting not to do a thing you know
what I mean like do something profound
or loud
huh guess not
oh this running is making me ill oh my
god the running just makes me so
nauseous Oh God
whoa hi rat come here
what was that
what was that
are you okay
ooh okay so something happened over here
what exactly did alright cool moment
ruined by grating metal things that you
would never want to do like sacrifice
children to a mythological creature of
some kind is he in the building now or
am i okay and when am I gonna get a
checkpoint
Oh oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my go go go
are you kidding me - are you why would
you do that developer I'm honestly
asking why would you do that
you have these story beats you have your
player go through these story beats you
surprise them with an encounter with the
monster that could very likely kill them
and in fact did and then send them all
the way back to experience the same
exact story beats that they just saw I
am honestly asking you because it just
makes for a very frustrating experience
I hope that's clear I'm not trying to be
mean or overly negative about it it's
just like that's kinda is shitty and
then things are random so I don't even
know where they're gonna be okay all
right I've got the key again back up
back through the blue and then I'm not
gonna be running so I'm not gonna run
out of breath
and I'm just gonna very nice and relaxed
calmly go through the blue door and
everything's gonna be great
oh my god I okay well okay interesting
what is this do okay some kind of a
puzzle one says H one says M I don't
know can I go up in here no probably not
what is that said a piece of a rat is
that tuft of hair probably all right who
knows what this does okay
so I've got to find something that's
gonna help me get through that but
whatever that is it's just gotta be some
combination of H and M but I don't know
where to find the answer for it I mean
where would the answer be
wow you're ugly maybe the answer is on
the clock
maybe the clock says what it is okay 10
+ 2 or 10 10 which is the time but I'm
gonna guess that 10 + 2 so H and M Oh
our minute wait so actually wait is that
just the back of the clock I don't know
why the back of the clock is made in
such a weird way but that seems to just
be the back of the clock so maybe I'm
affecting it yeah this is just the back
of the clock No
no [ __ ] off
okay so now they're at both in midnight
I don't know if that's good or bad okay
so I'm obviously missing something I got
to find some information that's gonna
help me figure out exactly what time
that should be at that's the answer why
oh no no no no oh my god go away I was
about to lose my breath why are stairs
the loudest things in the universe stop
talking what is wrong with you why would
you talk when there's a monster right
there this guy has the worst survival
instincts I've ever heard of anybody
ever I just have no idea what to do what
do I do
where's the information that I need to
continue on what about this one it says
that's not even a time tons of clocks
everywhere nothing to help me
got this guys shouting at the monster
why does the me the blind oh the monster
that can only hear why have you closed
your doors to the public oh my god why
why what did I do to offend you what did
I do
my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I had moved that minute hand was at 2:00
it is now at 1:00 I moved it all the way
around and I only needed to move it one
more I was wandering the entire premises
trying to figure out what it needed to
be and I just needed to listen and try
until it click
yeah you need to be quiet you really do
you really need to be quiet now what the
[ __ ] did I just do I have no idea why I
did that
why did I do that and now what I get to
do is I get to look around to see what
the hell it changed stop I did nothing
what changed
apparently [ __ ] all I don't know oh what
the [ __ ]
now now is when you're quiet now is when
you're gonna be quiet okay normally now
they would you know Boston hello what do
you mean talk to him through the window
then hi hello
[ __ ] hi what do i do what do i do
what do i do why do i have direction
do i have anything did anything drop
from the thing did a key drop am I about
to get what I need to get out of here
are you gonna come charging in for no
reason you better believe he is you
better believe he's coming in oh great
nice paint what go away what are you
doing
why I don't understand you're so
annoying that's it you're just oh my god
it was here oh great I would have been
looking across the whole goddamn map and
I would never have found it now where
the hell does this key go
okay he said he's coming to the back
entrance
that means this much must be that door
through the kitchen god I wish I could
have heard that
that's a good clue if that is what that
is
couldn't freaking hear it what are you
doing what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
[Music]
what are you doing he's broken good you
know what good good
frankly I'm glad if I were a back
entrance I'd be through the kitchen sure
wish I could have heard that still
struggling on those stairs buddy
still having a hell of a time you know
that's for the best nice food stores
oh very diverse very good oh good back
door yeah I'll go through here okay
all right great ha bud hardboard you
know you are the object of my rage bro
what are you doing where are you
thinking what you think you didn't
escape
ah nothing like a good old rat hook oh
well this seems pretty um walled off
what something about being trapped are
you trying to tell me I need to go back
up well wish I could tell what color
that was you know if I had to use one
word to describe this game it's uh it's
glacial everything moves progress is who
the [ __ ] is right I'm gonna I'm gonna
lose my marbles I'm gonna lose my
marbles I want to like the game I really
do I there's a lot of good things about
this game but some things are like built
to be aggravating it and I don't
understand why why Wow okay I'm okay I'm
okay I'm why [ __ ] okay I'm fine I'm fine
I'm forgiving I'm forgiving I have a key
I've no idea where it goes oh my god
hey officer you might want to look I
need to get out of here yeah that might
be good idea uh but you know the whole
monster thing
I oh my god what the [ __ ] is that what
the [ __ ] what enough
what the [ __ ] is that
what oh my god is following me what is
that will this game ever explain
anything to me I don't know why only one
checkpoint I don't know I don't
understand so help me understand you
okay um
all right I I want to be very clear I
don't ever want to like [ __ ] on a game
I'm not trying to there's a lot of good
things about this game that I want to
like but there's also a lot of things
about this game that are just not fun it
like shows hope around every corner and
and I want to like it I really do but
there's just so many things that get in
the way the pacing is so off the only
way I feel safe is to crawl and even
then I don't know what's gonna cause
this creature to come after me there's
no sense of stalking there's just a
sense of like how what is he gonna do
now instead of being scary it's just
aggravating and then there's like the
flashlight it's just like it's a it's a
chore it's a maintenance chore I don't
know if it causes noise I don't know if
it doesn't the running why even have a
run if you never use it not only does it
create noise and rob you of your breath
but also it's makes me nauseous
it physically makes me nauseous cuz it's
so these small things that just make it
really difficult it's also like the
styling is very good but also the glare
on the screen makes it just hard to see
and the noise
the noise it's so unbalanced and the
dialogue like I get it yes give the
character personality if you want to the
character personality hearing the same
lines over and over and over again drags
on it really drags on it's so strange
going from I really like this game in
the first episode to now I'm knee-deep
in and I'm just really tired of it I
want to see it to the end but not in
this episode so I hope that gives
reasoning to why I'm aggravated thank
you everybody so much for watching I'm
still gonna provide a link to this game
in the description below if you want to
play for yourself I recommend it try it
for yourself there's some scary things
about it there's some interesting things
about it but also everything I said I've
stand by I will see it to the end just
not in this episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching check the
description for more scary games that I
am playing the best and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]